what were the most ironic outcome that
the the currency that was invented as a
joke
in fact becomes the real currency
[Music]
why do you think those coins went to up
in balu
thank you for coming kapoor
[Music]
you have encountered a doge options
pet dodge snuggle doge feet dodge
you have chosen that doge the doge
is pleased
[Music]
that's why you're by t-o-g-e
your dogs what are you talking about
[Music]
so
dogecoin kind of started out as a very
light-hearted kind of just
joke that i that i made on the internet
by social media so via twitter
i put out a tweet talking about it and
then a community banded around it
and formed
[Music]
it's a really big experimental stage i
think for the internet
in the past we've just been creating and
sharing content but now we want to
bring more tangible value from the real
world
[Music]
100 of the money raised will help
sponsor the drilling of two wells
providing access to water as well as
providing
tools to retrieve and restore water
[Music]
just so i'm clear these people did this
on their own
i mean have you even talked to these
people who are trying to help you all
out
[Music]
like with facebook you like people's
comments well with dogecoin
there's a way you can you tip people so
it's a way of adding a tangible value to
something that you think they do is cool
so
there's a lot of cool things you can use
it to sponsor race cars too so that's
pretty cool
a 16 year old from chicago noticed josh
wise
having a good run in an underfunded car
early this season
and got all his fellow chives on
reddit.com's nascar
forum to chip in these dogecoins which
is an internet cryptocurrency
[Music]
it's got this dog for a symbol you know
it's what are those dogs called the
shiba inus early today
musk set off an investor frenzy with a
single word
doge in a tweeted reply to a picture he
then posted of a rocket heading to the
moon
[Music]
there is so much going on for dodge coin
right now
oh my goodness